Hallo zusammen!
Heute zeige ich euch ein einfaches Rezept für einen Rinderbraten aus dem Backofen
und ich glaube da hat jeder so sein Traditionsrezept von Oma oder von Mama.
Und ich mache es eben auf meine Art. Meine Art ist wie ihr alle wisst immer sehr einfach und easy halt nachzumachen
und auch ohne Alkohol, also Rotwein ist in meinem Rezept nicht mit dabei.
Das wollte ich euch vorab sagen weil das halt so typisch ist für Rinderbraten.
Aber meins schmeckt mindestens genauso lecker, da bin ich mir ziemlich sicher
weil ich mache das sehr oft, gerade so in den Wintermonaten.
Und jetzt brauchen wir natürlich zuallererst mal einen Rinderbraten
und der ist bei mir schon ohne Knochen und auch ohne Fett.
Also hier ist nur so ein kleines Stückchen Fett dran aber ansonsten ohne Fett.
Den habe ich gewaschen und hab ihn schon trocken getupft.
Und der erste Schritt, den machen wir hier in der Pfanne.
Ich hab hier 'ne Hochrandpfanne, ihr könntet aber auch einen Topf nehmen.
Da gebe ich jetzt zuallererst Butterschmalz rein und das wird dann richtig schön erhitzt
So und jetzt das Fleisch von allen Seiten schön scharf anbraten.
Den Braten nehmen wir dann nachdem wir ihn von allen Seiten kurz angebraten haben, einmal raus, zurück auf den Teller
und geben Salz und Pfeffer drauf. Und jetzt geht's weiter hier in unserer Pfanne.
Da gebe ich jetzt noch das restliche Butter Ghee dazu. Butter Ghee? Butterschmalz!
[Hamza] Butterschmalz!
[Kiki] Ich bin schon so an das Wort Butter Ghee gewöhnt!
So! Und anschließend gebe ich Tomatenmark dazu und Zimtstangen.
Da nehm ich gerne Zimtstangen. Ihr könntet sonst auch Zimt in Pulverform nehmen
aber ich finde, dass das mit Zimtstangen doch nochmal ein kleiner Unterschied im Geschmack ist.
So, die Zwiebeln jetzt nur ein paar Minuten mit andünsten.
Das waren jetzt bei mir grad so 2min auf mittlerer Stufe und jetzt kommt der Braten zurück.
Da mach ich mir hier ein bisschen Platz.
Einmal zurücklegen und anschließend mit Muskatnuss und Thymian nochmal schön würzen
und danach kommt auch schon der Rinderfond dazu.
[Hamza] Das wird 'n Festmahl!
[Kiki] Oh yes!
So jetzt ist unser Braten eigentlich bereit für den Ofen und jetzt kommt Omas Trick:
Wir nehmen jetzt einfach 2x Alufolie und geben das da drüber und verschließen dann den Topf.
So, kommt der Backofenteil.
Und zwar ist das ein Rezept, bei dem ihr ausnahmsweise mal nicht schnell kochen könnt oder das Gericht schnell funktioniert,
sondern das muss wirklich sehr langsam garen.
Und ich benutze heute den Samsung Dual Cook Flex Backofen.
Und ich hab euch auf Instagram schon angeteasert, dass ich den jetzt mal austeste
weil man dort einfach auch 2 Gerichte gleichzeitig backen kann oder garen kann besser gesagt.
Und das probiere ich heute, das ist der perfekte Test dafür.
Ich hab nämlich meinen Braten einmal unten reingeschoben, in den unteren Teil des Backofens,
den habe ich auf 180° C eingestellt.
Dort braucht er wirklich so 1½ bis 2h.
Ich hab jetzt 1kg Fleisch, es kommt halt auch immer auf die Dicke des Fleisches an.
Und oben mach ich jetzt schon mal eine leckere Beilage.
Da machen wir jetzt Kartoffeln und das zeige ich euch jetzt. Kommt!
Für die Ofenkartoffeln nehme ich jetzt festkochende Kartoffeln und die sind auch sehr klein,
daher werde ich sie nur halbieren mit meinem Wellenschneider.
Wenn sie sehr groß sind, dann viertelt sie gerne und anschließend können wir sie würzen.
Dafür brauchen wir erstmal als Basis Olivenöl, gebe ich direkt hier mit aufs Blech.
Und dann mag ich am liebsten Rosmarin, da könnt ihr jetzt getrockneten nehmen oder frischen.
Und dann noch Salz und Pfeffer, am besten frisch aus der Mühle.
Also die Ofen sind schon fertig für den Backofen und dadurch, dass -
[Hamza] Die Ofen sind fertig für den Backofen!
[Kiki] *lacht* Was?!
[Hamza] Die Kartoffeln!
[Kiki] Was hab ich denn gesagt?
[Hamza] Die Ofen!
[Kiki] Oh mein Gott, okay!
So, die Kartoffeln sind fertig vorbereitet
und durch die kleinere Größe sag ich mal brauchen sie wirklich nur 30min und sind dann gar.
Das kann ihr euch dann quasi so einplanen,
dass ihr das am Ende der Garzeit von eurem Braten reinschiebt.
Bei mir ist das jetzt der Fall. Und das Coole am Samsung Dual Cook Flex Backofen ist ja,
dass wir quasi 2 Garräume haben.
Wir haben zwar einen Backofen aber 2 Räume, in denen wir eben Dinge backen und garen können
und das zeige ich euch jetzt mal.
So, der obere Garraum ist jetzt für die Kartoffeln reserviert
und da backen sie oder garen sie bei 200° C vor sich hin.
Unten ist nach wie vor 180° C eingestellt
und im Prinzip könnte ich jetzt sogar einen Kuchen in einem der Garräume backen
und die Gerüche würden sich nicht gegenseitig annehmen.
Das finde ich ganz cool und das werde ich wie gesagt in den nächsten Wochen auch testen und euch weiterhin berichten.
Und wir haben hier 'ne flexible Tür, das kann ich euch auch gerne zeigen.
Das ist auch super wichtig weil die Kartoffeln könnt ihr nämlich zwischendurch wenden.
So, die Kartoffeln sind jetzt gar und unser Rinderbraten auch.
Ich hab jetzt beides aus dem Ofen geholt.
Und beim Rinderbraten mach ich's so, dass ich ihn immer erst 10min auf einem Schneidebrett entspannen lasse
und dann erst in dicke Scheiben schneide.
Und aus dem Rest machen wir jetzt eine leckere Soße.
Und dafür nehmt ihr euch jetzt ein bisschen Speisestärke, verrührt das mit Wasser
und dann kommt das mit da rein, wird einmal kurz aufgekocht
und dann Leute hab ich noch 'nen Extratipp für euch!
Ich hab heute rote Beete da, der ist schon vorgekocht - die ist schon vorgekocht!
Und ihr könntet aber auch frische rote Beete nehmen und die vor dem ganzen Garvorgang schon dazutun.
Und dann finde ich gibt das nochmal so einen extra tollen Geschmack!
Und anschließend noch salzen und pfeffern, ein bisschen abschmecken und dann sind wir auch schon fertig!
So, Soße nochmal abschmecken!
Perfekt! Also wirklich, mehr als Salz und Pfeffer braucht ihr am Ende gar nicht!
Die schmeckt sehr, sehr, sehr lecker!
Und fertig ist auch schon unser Festessen!
Und ich finde das war jetzt gar nicht so schwer und hat auch gar nicht so lange gedauert.
Wir feiern zwar kein Weihnachten aber Feiertage sind für uns auch immer so der Moment der Ruhe.
Alle Geschäfte zu, alle kommen einmal runter und dann sieht man auch seine Liebsten wieder.
Wenn's in diesem Jahr nicht so gut klappt, dann vielleicht hoffentlich im nächsten Jahr.
Und ich hoffe, dass euch das Rezept gefallen hat!
Ihr dürft mir auch gerne in die Kommentare schreiben, welches herzhafte Gericht ihr unbedingt mal von mir sehen möchtet,
dann zeige ich euch das natürlich und wünsche euch jetzt noch einen wunderschönen Tag
und bis zum nächsten Mal auf Kikis Kitchen! Tschüss!